nan
meji
me
はぁ
ん
ご紹介ありがとうございます慶應義塾志木高等学校3年の佐藤の正規です
さて皆さん最近グローバル化という言葉をよく耳にしませんか
インターネットの普及によって今や line や skype で世界の裏側へだっ
てリアルタイムで生きる
電話することができます
そして世界中どこへだって飛行機で簡単に旅することができます
存在の中で若者はグローバル化しなければならないとよく言われますか
一体グローバル化って何なのでしょうか
そう聞かれてみなさんは簡単に応えることができますか
将来必ず英語を使わなくてはならないからだ
将来国際的に活躍しなければならないから
創刊の方は多いことかもしれません
今日は私がこの1年の体験とそこから考えた私にとってのグローバルだとは何かについ
てお話ししようと思います
昔からの研究職に就きたいと考えていて高校に入り医学に興味を持ちらせた私は
慶応大学医学部で行われているグローバルサイエンスキャンパスというプログラムに
参加しています
そこで行われた講演会でんわたしの心に強く残っている言葉があります
それはドイツ人類学博士になりアメリカに渡って現在は日本で研究をダサっている
ベアー手配師比重教授の言葉です
科学者はグローバルでなければならない
科学者とは何か
科学者は誰もが知らないことを研究ししようとする職業です
それは常に疑問や質問の連続で結果が出ず
失敗することもあるでしょう
そしてグローバルとは何か
グローバルとは何か新しい状況に自分を探すことです
それも新しいことを知ろうとすることは疑問や質問が連続失敗することもあります
これら2つの本質は同じことなのです
だから科学者はグローバルでなければならない
暗く者は失敗する勇気を常に保たなければならない
そうおっしゃっていました
海外や英語に昔から興味があった私はこの言葉に後押しされ新たなプログラムに挑戦し
ました
エアーいう米国高校生国際交流プログラム
楽 cush st
私は1次選考の書類に書いた医師というイベント
グローバルとの関係について
二次面接で聞かれベアて先生の言葉を引用しました
どうにか合格することができたのですが
その時な彼女の言葉は受け売りで神に私の言葉にはなっていませんでした
ここで少し ush sd に説明すると
usa st はすべての滞在費が奨学金として支給され
京都に行ってアメリカの学生達とこのブルージーシャツなように高校生外交官
high school diploma つとして交流できる素晴らしいプログラム
でした
そこではアメリカ全土また日本全国から選抜された
それぞれ20名の生徒たちが
2人一組のルームメイトとして10日間常に一緒に行動することが求められました
そんな ush sd には3つのキーワードがありました
ん
チャレンジ常に自分自身を刺激し新しいこんなに挑戦する
そしてプライド自分自身が家をしてきたことに誇りを持ち
求められていることを理解する
それは単におごりではなく自分自身を深く理解しなければ成し遂げられる事ではあり
ません
そしてリスペクト
周りや相手への感謝の念や尊敬の念を持つだけではなく相手に伝えること
これらは初めただ体されていただけなものでした
しかし
プログラムが進むにつれこれらの g ワードは私の中でとても深い意味を持つように
なります
実際の exchange では前々から準備をしてきた
プレゼンテーションやクラブ活動また様々なアクティビティを通して日米双方の文化や
歴史を学び国際交流を深めました
中でも京都市内を観光して幕末について学んだ kyoto trip や
アメリカのダンスパーティーであるブログでデートメイトと過ごしておりは
暗い中でロマンチックな音楽が流れまさにとろけるような時間でした
そしてさあなかなか学校では行わないディスカッションでは終始
アメリカの学生達に圧倒し続けられました
彼らはどんなもんだいたとえセンシティブなものに対しても必ず自分自身の意見を持ち
周りに積極的に発信していました
自分自身の意見を持っていても発言することが恥ずかしかったりまた何か問題に対して
意見すら持っていなかったことも多々あった私はチャレンジの大切さを痛感させられ
ました
その反面日本の学生たちは
相手を尊敬し最後はの話を聞くリスペクトの能力には長けているとも感じました
ただアメリカの学生達その思いは持つだけではなく言葉にして伝えることの大切さを
学びました
そしてアメリカの学生たちのチャレンジ精神は彼らのプライドから来ていると思うの
ですか
その姿勢は短時に議論の時の攻撃的な姿勢にもつながっていました
自分の長所だけではなく端子も認めることが正しいプライドを持つことなどと聞かされ
ました
こうして私はアメリカと日本双方の調子が単勝を感じました
しかし皆さんアメリカと日本の違いを知ること
日本や外国の違いを知ることがグローバル化だということはもともと知っていると思わ
れませんでしたか
私自身このプログラム思えるまでグローバル化とは海外にて英語を使う
そんな経験をすることだと漠然と考えていました
しかしグローバル化とは単に国際交流だけで終わるものでなかったのです
こちらもこの優しそうな彼が you shed の僕のルームメイト税国です
当確は常に同じ人と過ごすとその人が上辺だけではない
深いところまでわかりとてもたくさんなことが起こるものです
彼は私が目を離した隙にすぐにエアコンの設定温度最低の15度にするので私はいつも
環境に悪いとガミガミ言っていました
真夏の40度近くにもなる京都で私はいつも凍えていたのです
そしてこちらに私の方はお風呂に入るのが大好きで毎日30分以上は湯船に入ってい
ました
そうすると何度か約束に遅れ仮に母親のように叱られたことも多々ありました
そのたびことだけではなく彼との衝突や擦れ合いはそれだけでは決して終わりません
でした
医学部を志望していたはたちと同じように彼の夢も医師になることでした
そんな彼が日本に来て初めて私にくれたプレゼントか
この心肺蘇生法略して cpr 方の練習の人形でした
私はこれにとても驚きどうせそれを持ってきたのと聞くと
はアメリカで10名活動をしていてその一環で cpr 4周りに広めている
そう言いました
同じ高校生ですね救急車を運転し救命活動している
そして決して恥ずかしがりもせず周りに cpr 方懸命に広めている
とても衝撃的でした
考えてみれば私は生命の不思議や医学の学問自体に興味があっただけ
もっと言ってしまえば閣内でも成績の高い者たちが行く
医学部に憧れていただけでした
人を治す医師という仕事に号から考えたことがなかったことに気づかされたのです
そして彼は人柄も良く常に周りに声をかけて気を配っていました
そんな彼があるいつも活発な女の子を励ましていたので後で理由を聞くとその7個が
ホームシックにかかっていたからだと言いました
私はそんなことにまったく血が付くこともできなかったのです
一度は彼に君は医者になりたいんじゃなく医学の研究をしたいだけなんじゃないか
そう言われたこともあります
今までの私は勉強して新しい仕事を知ることはとても好きでした
しかし他人と2か悪い
自分の本当の思いをさらけ出して伝えたり相手の本当の思いを聞こうとすることから無
意識に逃げていました
スパイが強かったのかもしれません
しかしみんなに慕われる彼と接するうち
尾根で語り合い時に衝突するうちに
自分が人と関わることから逃げていたことに気づき
痛いことを痛感させられたのです
そして同時に私も彼のような人になりたいと
彼のように人を深くし
相手に尽くせるようなそんな人になりたいとすごく願うようになったのです
さてグローバル化とは何かそれを私にとって違いをすることでした
しかしこれはただの違いではありません
人と人の間で相手を深く知ろうとすることだったんです
これは決して簡単なことではありません
相手へのリスペクトの気持ちがなければ相手の話を最後まで聞きそれを受け入れること
ができません
そして自分への正しいプライドがなければ自分の長所だけではなく
端子も認め
相手の長所を素直に吸収することができません
そしてベアーテ先生のおっしゃる通り相手を深く知ろうとすることはそれだけで大変な
挑戦
チャレンジでもあります
そしてだからこそグローバル化というものは日本や外国
そして英語というものとは全くたん英語というものが放出ではないと私は考えます
あなたの家族や友だちとの間でだってグローバル化は成し遂げられるのです
そして医者や科学者だけがグローバル化すればいいわけでもありません
決して特別なことではないのです
ここにいる皆さんがグローバル化しなければならない
そしてそのチャンスを持っているのです
私は自分にとってのグローバル化も見つけ
相手と深く関わることから逃げていた自分に気づき
相手を深く知る喜びを知り人生が変わりました
usa chesty が終わり私は現在グローバルサイエンスキャンパスで研究活動
を行っています
患者さんと深く接することができる臨床の道と自分の一つの夢でもあった研究との道で
模索中ですが
高校生の間に研究活動ができていることまた今この場で皆さんの前に立てていることも
自分なりのグローバル化にあってだと強く感じています
最後に私の大好きな言葉を紹介したいと思います
no rain no rainbow
辛いことコーナーなことに挑戦しなければ決して素晴らしいミラーをやっていきません
逆に言えば辛いことに自ら挑戦しそれを乗り越えたなら一素晴らしい未来があなたに
訪れるでしょう
みなさんも自分にとってのグローバル化を見つけそこに向かって突き進んでいって
ください
そうすればきっと今までとは違った想像もしなかった自分があなたを待っていること
でしょう
どうもありがとうございました